foreign
[Music]
it's a pleasure to be with you here
today thank you for joining us
so I will be presenting a tiny bit what
we were doing uh during 2022 for Autumn
Drive also but first of all I want to
highlight again the beauty of Clio
probably everyone here knows uh how
important is the visualization of the
building blocks of life francions so you
know the human body contains between 80
000 and 400 000 proteins and those
proteins are very important they are
essential for life functions from ground
repair metabolism scripture and to
disease resistance so understanding this
cluster of those proteins is very very
key to be able to understand not only
the diseases but to develop new
Therapeutics to feed those diseases so
obviously cryolian as you know already
here is the fastest growing structural
archeology method for characterizing
proteins and pathogens and I would like
to show you you know how or some of the
those examples of how cryo en is
impacting on Research in human health so
the first example I want to show you
today you can see here in the left side
was working in collaboration with the
MRC lab in the UK and using cryolian
single particle analysis we were able to
understand and discover a new type
property so it's a neurodegenerative
disease and we were able to doing this
isolating from brain passions
developments and analyzing the
of those filaments so this was a very
important Discovery using cryolian
single particle analysis in the middle I
have another example for you this is
better therapies against Ebola and this
work was done in collaboration with the
Hoya Institute in San Diego California
so we were able doing this again cryo in
a single particle analysis to really
understand and to really discover two
human antibodies they were able to
Target these Ebola biosis like they are
very very little as you already know
and the last example I want to show you
today is how using cryo in single
particle analysis we can really
understand cancer and we can really
discover new Therapies in this
particular example I want to focus on
the kinase this piano's kinase is a
membrane protein like it's very very
challenging to do and to get the
structural information by
crystallography as you know membrane
proteins can be very tricky so using
cryo in single particle analysis we we
are totally able to really understand
the structure of this protein and to
really develop new Therapeutics and new
Therapies
so now like I saw you uh and I hope you
know uh you understand the importance
and the impact like Ryobi and is
plaguing you know nowadays in the
spiritual biology Arena as well as the
scientific Community I would like to
show you right now as well you know uh
how uh Tundra specifically or
entry-level single particle analysis
microscope is playing as well a very
important role in this structural uh
Insight or structural pathology Arena so
uh Tundra is as I say a side NPR level
and a second entry level single particle
analysis microscope like was launched in
November 2020 and uh it's very easy of
use and it has artificial intelligence
so even for people like there are no
experts in electron microscopy they can
definitely and very easily use of tundra
so I can show you here are some of the
examples of the structural biology
information you will be able to obtain
with the tundra for example we have in
this case a 330 kilodalton membrane
protein like we were able to obtain
using the tundra a 4.2 ascon resolution
you can see as well in the middle the
200 kiloval membrane protein Gaba
receptor like it's a very important
Target you know for a developing new
Therapeutics against concept and we were
able to obtain this 3D polio African for
instance again 7000 proteosome another
very very important Target for different
therapeutic uh you know developments and
using Tundra we were able to obtain a
three Astron resolution of this protein
and you can see other examples here at
the bottom for example the ribose on a
3.5 the AAP a 3.5 as well and of course
Apple ferritin like is the test control
sample for single particle analysis at
2.6 in only 6 hours of data collection
so this is a very very impressive uh you
know instrument where you will be able
to screen optimize your samples very
easily very ease of use and you will be
able to obtain already very important
structural information
[Music]
with that being said I want to tell you
as well like in 2022 we were able to
schedule different uh Tundra roads of
maps and you can see like Tundra is
coming to your institution or maybe have
been already there so those are the
places that we schedule our fundra
workshops to representations during 2022
but I want to reassure you if you miss
some of these workshops you don't need
to worry we are planning to keep moving
with those two representations and
Tundra virtual Demos in 2023 so please I
am hoping that you will be able to join
us in 2023 and with that thank you so
much for your attention today
thank you very much to the netapport for
that fantastic demonstration
and here this will just be a summary
slide before we transition into some
question and answers but really what
what I'm trying to highlight with this
slide is just the broad range of
applications that
the tundra can assist with and cryo
electron microscopy more generally is
able to
help with and so obviously you can do
you know so-called traditional
structural determination using Chrome
electron microscopy in the tundra
specifically and we have some examples
here that Natalia during her
introduction elaborated on in more
detail but there's one area that you
know we we didn't touch upon but core
electron microscopy can really help with
nanoparticle characterization and so we
have some examples here
of how that's able to to add research we
can answer some questions about that in
the Q a if there's any questions there
and
really the the key point that you would
have seen during the demo is just how
straightforward and accessible the the
tundra is and so we have a diagram here
in the sample optimization line where
you're using that structural information
that you're getting from the tundra to
help optimize your sample and as you saw
with the nice resolutions you can get on
the tundra you can obviously be
satisfied in some cases with
that level of data but if you're
required to move to a high resolution
well you have already
optimize your sample so when you go to a
glacios or a Creole or some other
instrument you then have a lot more
confidence that your sample is going to
be able to achieve you know whatever
resolution you're looking for
and within all of this when you saw the
nanoport operating the tundra I think
probably the key takeaway was just how
you know straightforward and accessible
the microscope is so
um you know it's possible that some
people approach chromium with the idea
that it's going to be a little bit
difficult and maybe not so accessible to
you know a range of different
researchers and Labs but really you can
see just how straightforward and how
much effort has gone into really
optimizing and improving the process so
that you know anyone
more or less can access car electron
microscopy and operate these microscopes
and so I think with that
um just once again thank you to the
nanoport for the great demo and we'll
transition into into question and
answers thank you
hello everyone and Welcome to our 2022
lab Roots webinar series my name is Tara
nilis and I am the regional market
development manager here for the Thermo
Fisher Life Sciences electron microscopy
team we're so glad to have everybody
here with us today
during today's session we have an
exciting lineup prepared for you today
it's a combination of presentations from
our scientists as well as a demo from
our nanoport of the tundra the Thermo
Fisher Scientific Tundra cryo
transmission electron microscope
so for today's webinar we encourage you
to ask questions we'll have some time
for a q a at the end so please do feel
free to type any questions that you
might have in the question box and click
Send for any questions that we don't
have time for today we will follow up
with you via email to make sure that all
of today's questions get answered
we've had a really busy three months
since the tundra instrument has been
installed in the Nano port and over the
last three months we've had many events
at universities around the US so these
events have included us speakers doing
scientific presentations as well as the
nanoport connecting to do a live
demonstration for all of the attendees
the
sessions that we've had have been
extremely well received and we've had a
great number of users anywhere from
starting users to cryo to em all the way
through directors of priorem facilities
looking to expand their capabilities
using the tundra cryote em
now I'd like to introduce our speakers
today
Natalia Duvall is a biochemist and
protein engineering specialist with more
than 15 years experience in single
particle prior electron microscopy as
well as immunogenic design efforts for
vaccine achievement she received her
doctoral degree in Biochemistry from the
University of Lube in Belgium in October
2017 she joined at NCIS the director of
the am lab and the team lead for cryo em
section at the center for molecular
microscopy she was responsible for the
management of a wide portfolio of
projects related mainly to cancer and
HIV diseases she has authored over 70
Publications in high impact scientific
journals as such as Nature and Science
she joined them officer scientific in
January of 2021 as senior scientist
senior product specialist for electron
microscopy in her current position she
is supporting em in the east coast and
midwest U.S
doing today's demo is very bot who is an
application scientist at in life
sciences at thermoofficial scientific he
obtained his Ms in biophysics from all
India Institute of Medical Sciences New
Delhi and his PhD in biophysics from the
Ohio State University
as an application scientist he conducts
training performs data acquisition and
delivers demonstrations on various tem
workflow related products in the Life
Sciences
prior to joining Thermo Fisher
Scientific Veer utilized his expertise
in structural biology biochemistry and
biophysics to contribute to cancer
research his work led to understanding
how cancer-causing virus hijacks human
protein Machinery to leverage
integration of viral DNA into human DNA
his work on intracellular membrane
Remodeling and carcinogenous revealed
novel details of how bar family of
proteins deforms membranes in various
processes such as autophagy and
apoptosis
and our final speaker for today is Zubin
Brown who obtained his undergraduate
degree from the University of Sydney
Australia and his PhD in structural
biology from Osaka University in Japan
his postdoctoral work was completed at
Columbia University in the lab of Nobel
Prize winner Jacob Frank and he uses
cryo-em to study the structure of
hepatitis C virus internal ribosome
entry site as it hijacks the canonical
cellular translation machinery
his experienced with all aspects of
cryo-em project including operation of
high-end microscopes data collection
strategies computational analysis and
model building he recently joined Thermo
Fisher Scientific as senior product
specialist
in today's session we'll start off with
a brief introduction to cry OEM followed
by a live demonstration from nanoport
and then wrap up as we move into our q a
session now we're ready to learn more
from our speakers Natalia over to you to
start us off
hi everyone it's a pleasure to be with
you here today thank you for joining us
so I will be presenting a tiny bit what
we were doing uh during 2022 for Autumn
Drive also but first of all I want to
highlight again the beauty of Clio
probably everyone here knows uh how
important is the visualization of the
building blocks of life functions so you
know the human body contains between 80
000 and 400 000 proteins and those
proteins are very important they are
essential for life functions from ground
repair metabolisms structure and to
disease resistance so understanding the
structure of those proteins is very very
key to be able to understand not only
the diseases but to develop new
Therapeutics to feed those diseases so
obviously cryo em as you know already
here is the fastest growing structural
archeology method for characterizing
proteins and pathogens and I would like
to show you you know how or some of
those examples of how cry OEM is
impacting on Research in human health so
the first example I want to show you
today you can see here in the left side
was working in collaboration with the
MRC lab in the UK and using cryolian
single particle analysis we were able to
understand and discover a new type
property so it's a neurodegenerative
disease and we were able to doing this
isolating from brain passions
developments and analyzing
of those filaments so this was a very
important Discovery using Crayola and
single particle analysis in the middle I
have another example for you this is
better therapies against Ebola and this
work was done in collaboration with La
Jolla Institute in San Diego California
so we were able doing this again Clarion
single particle analysis to really
understand and to really discover two
human antibodies they were able to
Target these Ebola viruses like they are
very very little as you already know
and the latest example I want to show
you today is how using cryo in single
particle analysis we can really
understand cancer and we can really
discover new Therapies in this
particular example I want to focus on
the kinase this piano's kinase is a
membrane protein like it's very very
challenging to do and to get the
structural information by
crystallography as you know membrane
proteins can be very tricky so using
cryogen single particle analysis we we
are totally able to really understand
the structure of this protein and to
really develop new Therapeutics and new
Therapies
so now like I saw you uh and I hope you
know uh you understand the importance
and the impact like Rio Ian is plaguing
you know nowadays in the structural
biology Arena as well as the scientific
Community I would like to show you right
now as well you know uh how uh Tundra
especially specifically or entry-level
single particle analysis microscope is
playing as well a very important role in
this structural uh Insight always
cultural patiology Arena so uh Tundra is
as I say is entity level uh entry level
single particle analysis microscope like
was launched in November 2020 and uh
it's very easy of use and it has
artificial intelligence so even for
people like they have no experts in
electrical microscopy they can
definitely and very easily use of tundra
so I can show you here some of the
examples of this cultural biology
information you will be able to obtain
with the tundra for example we have in
this case a 330 kilowatt on membrane
protein like we were able to obtain
using the tundra 4.2 ascon resolution
you can see as well in the middle the
200 kilowatts of membrane protein
is a very important Target you know for
a developing new Therapeutics against
cancer and we were able to obtain this
3D polio African France again 700 kilos
proteosome another very important Target
for different therapeutic uh you know
developments and using Tundra we were
able to obtain a three astronaut
resolution of this protein and you can
see other examples here at the bottom
for example the ribose on a 3.5 the aab
a 3.5 as well and of course Apple
ferritin like is the test control sample
for single particle analysis at 2.6 in
only six hours of data collection so
this is a very impressive uh you know uh
instrument where you will be able to
screen optimize your samples very easily
very ease of use and you will be able to
obtain already very important structural
information
[Music]
with that being said I want to tell you
as well like in 2022 we were able to
schedule different uh Tundra road so
maps and you can see like Tundra is
coming to your institution or maybe have
been already there so those are the
places that we are scheduled are Tundra
workshops to representations uh during
2022 but I want to reassure you if you
miss some of these workshops you don't
need to worry we are planning to keep
moving with those student
representations and Tundra virtual Demos
in 2023 so please I am hoping that you
will be able to join us in 2023 and with
that thank you so much for your
attention today
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome to the children demonstration
and we're back I'm an application
scientist with Thermo and I'll walk you
through the demo let's get started
so there are three elements uh to our
system the microscope uh
the cryo loading workstation and the
microscope PC we will start with
railroading Workstation
and to begin with we have our on system
display which is right here I'm going to
share a live copy of it for sake of
clarity so let's move to share my screen
so here uh there are three buttons on
the left pane starting with status
we can see that
loading workstation transfer device and
the microscope all are good
we can see some additional details for
example the cassette has a sample
in slot number four
the microscope is already at liquid
nitrogen temperature and we have an
estimated time of 22 hours remaining on
it uh before we refill it with liquid
nitrogen
then the second button is actions which
hosts most of the actions that will need
to be performed
load unload samples from the cassette
set temperature mode load sample to the
microscope
unload sample refill liquid nitrogen
crowd work crowd cycle loading
Workstation
uh maintenance maintenance is of course
reserved for uh our system engineers and
then there is an available recovery
button uh should there be any
misalignment in the loading workstation
you will have an option uh to try to
recover it by pushing the recovery
button
the cassette gives details of what
samples are in the cassette
one of them will be loaded uh into the
microscope
so our uh in addition to all these
details I also want to emphasize that
there are several animations that come
along with every single action for
example if I need to refill liquid
nitrogen let me push this button
a guided animation tells me that I need
to open the valve on the nitrogen tank
counterclockwise and then there are four
sensors in the loading chamber which are
updated live in this animation
and the four sensors correspond to four
levels
we need to have liquid nitrogen up to
level three for us to be able to
manipulate the sample and transfer our
grids to the microscope so just like
this every action uh has corresponding
animations which are very helpful for
new users
so with that if I'm to start out an
experiment the first thing I would do is
to set the temperature mode so I'll push
this button and select uh either
negative stain or liquid nitrogen
temperature for today I have already
selected liquid nitrogen temperature
because I am working with cryogenic
samples
so I'll proceed with that and then let's
uh let's move to see more details of the
procedure of loading the grid to the
microscope
so here the next action to be performed
is on on system display where I say load
unload samples from cassette I'll push
this button and the cassette will move
out
okay
there are several there are several
cutouts in the in this loading chamber
uh there are
five cutouts for your auto grid uh
boxes so to speak
right here
there is a dedicated cutout for your
cassette
it does the cassette
is identical to that used in glacios and
Creos but here
it is an integral part of the loading
workstation so it does not come off and
another point to remember is that
only slots one through five are
available for the transfer device so
your grids that are available that you
load into slots one through five are can
be used to transfer to the microscope
there is a dedicated cutout
for clipping as well so if you want to
sandwich your grids in place you can do
that here
and then there are some cutouts for your
tools
to be stored while you're using it
so here let me
transfer
a grid
so this is indeed an auto grid and it is
fully compatible with glaciers and krios
as well
I'm loading it into
slot number three
let me check if it is properly engaged
and once that is done
I will again
go back to my on system display
I loaded the Grid in slot number three I
can edit some details if I want to here
and if I
need to I can edit some details and then
continue
and the cassette will return
to be ready for the transfer device
so here then the next action is of
course I want to load a grid to the to
the microscope uh again
I push this button that says load sample
to trans temp and then I select one of
the five slots there are only two grids
here in slots three and four I select
slot number three and I say transfer
sample to 10.
foreign
account don't starts which takes about
eight minutes to complete during this
countdown
the first thing that will happen is that
the loading work session tells the
microscope that a grid is coming to you
so be ready in order to get uh not for
Microsoft to be able to receive the grid
the turbo pump on the microscope that
starts ramping up to minimize the analog
pump time
uh then again uh what's happening on
this end is the transfer device uh the
semi-automated loader housed in the
transfer device is being physically
cooled by its own thermal Mass uh for
first few minutes and towards the end of
the countdown uh the gripper arm in the
transfer device will grab the grip and
return to the housing in the transfer
device
that will be followed by an evacuation
for about a minute so your grid will be
cut contamination free in the transfer
device
uh as I just said
travelodent workstation talks in the
background to the microscope all the
time so there is uh so they are in
synchrony
while the countdown is being completed
let's go through some some additional
elements uh of both loading workstation
as well as the microscope uh so to start
with of course uh there is the on system
display which we uh described in detail
just just a while ago then there are two
places uh on either side of the transfer
device where you can store your tools uh
just as you can see here
the the slots are heated so both of the
pads are heated so your tools are ready
to be used whenever you are
in addition to the storage area for
tools we have heated pads here uh below
the bench top as well so that you can
work comfortably the level of crowd
loading workstation can also be adjusted
there is a lever provided here to do
that if you're not comfortable with the
height setting
there is an emergency shutoff button
available and what you cannot see on the
screen is a reset button available here
indeed the most uh important part of the
crowd loading workstation is right here
the semi-automated loader which is
housed inside the transfer device and
which we'll see in action in just a
little bit
so with that in mind let's uh move on
and take a walk around the microscope so
I'll start with the front
the microscope is
fully enclosed
and there is a dedicated on system
display available on the microscope it
has fewer buttons the most useful button
available on on 16 just like is the
craft cycle button so uh here graph
cycling the microscope becomes super
easy you can just push the button and
the craft cycle is completed you do not
have to worry about emptying the
microscope viewer or drying it unlike
some other systems there is an emergency
shutoff button available right here and
this is the housing so to speak weird uh
channel of
containing the semi-automated loader is
connected on the microscope and and the
transfer device will enter
right with that let's take a look at the
back side of the microscope and some
other ingredients
so on top we have the electron source
which is a 100 KV extract in this case
uh followed by the accelerator stack
and uh the column here
uh and this is where the beam interacts
with your uh sample as your objective
lens system uh with the indeed the
electronically controlled apertures
right here uh
following that is your projector lens
system and towards the end of the column
uh first the flow screen and uh then
your Theta F camera C drive camera
writes 14 frames per second and enables
you to uh get a four times enhanced
signal to noise ratio relative to the uh
16m camera for example
uh so uh the vacuum system is oil free
in the system uh so we have for example
iron getter pumps uh for the gun and
column uh we have turbo pumps both for
air lock as well as Drive cycling
uh
as I said just a while ago
the microscope viewer uh is an integral
part of the microscope it can be cryo
cycled with push of a button it is it
has a capacity of 5.5 liters and uh
one complete fill of the juror lasts
about three days
and that enables you to acquire Spa data
easily which is something that is quite
difficult for a traditional side entry
systems with that we can return to
our countdown
towards the end of the countdown
the bridge returns to the semi-automated
loader and uh the transfer device is
evacuated
so uh so your grid is kept contamination
free
so here the actions I'll need to perform
are simply to take the transfer device
out and insert it in the tunnel on the
microscope
all right
so here the lights on the microscope are
blinking
just a simple visual cue for me
and the transfer device is inserted so
uh during this process
the grid will be transferred from the
transfer device to the stage and as you
can see this process is
quite uh quite a lot simple simpler than
uh or traditional side entry trial
holders
another thing uh that uh that some of
you may already appreciate is that uh
compared to side entry holders uh to get
identity holders it's
relatively easy to insert and rest as
well as if you want to recover a grid it
is also quite easy to perform a long uh
Spa data collection and that is because
traditional side entry Drive holders
they do require a constant refilling of
liquid nitrogen whereas here we uh once
the transfer is complete we return the
transfer device back
after it's housing in the traveling
workstation and the grid is protected
and kept safe in the microscope itself
so here uh once we return the transfer
device uh to the crowd holding
workstation there's
it would be a returns to atmospheric
pressure and vented with dry nitrogen to
keep it contamination free and ready for
next transfer
from the microscope this process takes
about two minutes
so in addition to the eight minutes of
the initial Countdown the whole process
takes about 10 minutes for a complete
transfer
so the actions here are again quite
simple I take the transfer device out
linking lights
visual cue
and I insert it
and the learning workstation and it's as
simple as that
so with that we can move on uh just to
see if how data is acquired or how
screening is performed using Chandra so
I'll share my screen for that
so right off the bat we see that uh
there is a simplified uh
version of if you available here for
tundra we have available uh
two things that I already want to point
out one is the choice of experiment type
we have screening
medium resolution and high resolution so
if we look at these experiment types in
screening we have a larger field of view
smaller pixel size so we that enables
quick screening of our grid for ice
quality and such
for high resolution in contrast we have
a field of view that's about three times
smaller and also a smaller pixel size
that
increases your chances of getting high
resolution
structures
so uh in it in addition to that what
simplifies the workflow of tundra
significantly is availability of traffic
lights
so here uh
most of the components of the microscope
are already covered so for example
vacuum Source acquisition column Optics
storage
loader column and alignments
and uh
how are alignments performed it's as
simple as pushing this recover button
so if there's anything off the recover
button becomes available uh
and the microscope can recover itself
specifically for alignments uh here if I
look the traffic light has already
turned blue and some of the alignments
are expired so in this scenario if I
push the recover button all the
alignments will be recovered
and this already illustrates uh the
contrast which of Tundra with several
other systems where you need significant
training and some expertise uh to
perform all these alignments
so here uh let's start with acquiring an
atlas burst
we
click a new session
and give at Atlas a sensible name
foreign
Atlas acquisition takes about three
minutes to complete
during that time let's take a short tour
of epu
so we start with the landing page as I
just described it houses uh
three different experiment types and if
we want we can modify them so here for
example uh I have modified some of them
and it's as simple as making any
modification and clicking on the plus
button and then I can save my
modifications uh
to uh as I wish
and the next important feature as I
discussed in detail is the traffic
lights button which makes uh
recovery as well as alignments very
streamlined so it's all done with push
of a button
then this workflow in general uh
goes from left to right and top to
bottom here in the taskbar
there are only four available tabs
preparation Atlas Auto functions and epu
for a typical genre workflow
you really need to go to only Auto
functions and EPO tabs Auto functions if
you after screening you like your grid
and you want to acquire a full spa data
set you would go to optimize Beam for
some final alignments such as
astigmatism comma finding parallel
elimination
Etc and all of those alignments
again will be performed with push of a
button so we say optimize beam and push
the start button we can select an
aperture objective aperture if we desire
to do so
and then apertures will also be centered
as part of the alignment
s and uh the last tab is epu tab of epu
which is where we set up
the automated data acquisition
let's look at some more details and then
overview of what goes on here so each
tab has a dedicated ribbon to it which
has a group of functions for example for
Preparation we have all these presets
that here are predefined for you because
we did select an experiment type
so all of the presets for example Atlas
preset they have dedicated optic
settings like exposure time
magnification illumination mode there's
micro probe or Nano probe size of the
aperture Etc that is associated with it
if we move down here in the taskbar uh
available to us are calibrate image
shifts and Atlas Optics alignments as
well a rarely used option
moving to the right we have Atlas tab
which is acquiring Atlas right now
and again this is the Imaging area where
all images appear through Atlas
acquisition as well as your epu
automated data acquisition run
then uh is uh are a few boxes on your
right side
to start with there's a box for
notifications here on top there's the
status box
which is a live log of what the software
is doing at the moment
there is
a histogram that is associated with each
image and there is the image metadata
here
so here Atlas acquisition is already
complete and following uh following the
completion of Atlas acquisition there is
a clustering that if you execute
to
the group uh grid scares that have
similar ice quality
so here for example uh
I'm thinking that the red grid scares
they have too many uh
broken areas so I don't like red
from what are left
let's say that I like cyan grid scares I
know the sample does like to go to
thickerize so I leave sign selected and
I unselect all the other colors
and with that I can move on to
set up an epu data acquisition
so I create a new session
I'm asked if I want to use the
preferences that are saved I would say
yes that's a time saving feature
I give the session a sensible name
I would between
automated and manual I select manual
that will allow me some additional
customization of selecting holes
via a selection brush
acquisition mode accurate versus faster
I'll select faster so I can use
aberration free image shift that moves
the beam
uh to the neighboring areas of the
sample
as opposed to moving the stage
increasing the throughput of the data
acquisition significantly
I also have the option to live monitor
the data that are being acquired to do
that I need to connect the EQ session to
and to EQ quality monitor which is
housed in Athena so right now I am
connected to Athena and I can if I want
to connect
to a particular location in the EU
quality Monitor and then
it uh the data that are being acquired
will be live processed and I I'll have a
better Insight on uh on different
metrics for example uh CTF astigmatism
Etc that my images do have
uh for this demo we are not doing that
so here I give a location uh
to the data that will be written to the
offload server to say apply
the taskbar is populated with
new options here so I go to scare
selections and here you can see that
the cyan color that I selected uh is
already
correlated to the epu session I can
further deselect some grid scares
if I want or I can uh
unselect all of them and select
a few grid squares
if I want to
the next uh
function is pole selection
so here I
just go to auto eccentric
that will drive the stage automatically
to a selected grid scale as we can see
here in the status
box
and once the stage move is complete The
Eccentric height will be found
automatically
uh and that procedure invokes applying
positive and negative beam tilts
and maximizing the correlation between
the images coming from positive beam
tilt and negative beam tilt
the point where the maximum is reached
is The Eccentric height
once The Eccentric height is estimated
it will be
populated here at stage Z and epu will
remember the
eccentric height for that grid scare
for the remainder of the data
acquisition
once The Eccentric height is found
the new image will be acquired
and
will appear here
and as I said this is a live log
I like reading what's going on here at
the current moment
and here already we see that uh
the ice quality is reasonable enough it
is on the thicker side but that is
necessary for this sample
uh
and we can go to
the next button here measure hole size
I can increase the
contrast of the image
to my liking
and let's say find holes
and
if there are a couple of options here I
can tweak the
polls that are selected by play at the
histogram so I can
move the sliders from left or right to
select more or few holes so the slider
on the right to remove dry holes if
there are any and the slider from the
left to remove the holes that have
thicker eyes
I can also perform the selection right
from the screen where I can set the ice
filter lower bound or upper bound
and uh
I can also
not select all the holes but select some
of the holes within the window of
grayscale that I have selected
how do I do that I use this fast
screening option here turn it on and
select a number of locations
so here for example I can tell if you
that uh collects data from a maximum
number of 10 locations and that is an
approach that I can take for screening
purposes so here let me turn that off
let's
move stage to an area where holes are
selected
and move to the next step
which is defining the template
let's push the acquire button
and
that will require an image
at eucentric height Optics
setting and here there are two areas
that already appear one is where my
image my data would be acquired
and second is autofocus area
both of these are populated from my
saved preferences so you can see that
the list of the focus values is already
populated here for the data acquisition
area and the routine that I would like
to use for autofocus is also already
populated here so for example here I am
employing autofocus after a distance of
10 microns another option is to do it
every single time to do it never or to
do it once per office cluster if I want
I can of course tweak my template and
let's for example say
after
centering means autofocus will be
performed once per office cluster
and let's try out this template
so
if you will start by taking an image at
Holy Centric height preset
and centering the
centering the area of acquisition
automatically
following which autofocus will be
performed again beam tilts will be
employed
positive beam tilt and negative beam
tilt and cross correlation between the
two images will be used
to estimate Focus
right and there's our image
and here already I can see that some of
the particles do look quite good
so this is a side view of KLH and this
is from top down KLH does have G5
symmetry which means C pi propagating
along an axis so this is the view from
top down and this is the view from side
in addition what I can learn from this
already is that there are a lot of
disintegrated particles so this several
of the subunits in fact many of the
subunits have already screen uh already
disintegrated
and what that tells me that I do need to
revisit biochemistry so for example here
I can perform an additional sizing step
before I collect a full
spa driven data set on the sample
uh at this moment uh in uh in contrast
to uh revisiting my biochemistry if I'm
already if I were already happy with the
sample
I would uh perform some additional
alignments uh before acquiring full spa
data set and uh how would I do that
I would go to auto functions tab
I would select an aperture let's say 100
Micron aperture and say set
and then click on the start button so
this is a something that I again want to
emphasize that even in the scenarios
where where you want to collect a full
spa data set all the alignments are
fully automated and performed with a
push button
so here uh
the program will start with
finding eccentric height for the sample
for every single grid square and then
perform all the other alignments such as
minimizing astigmatism Auto coma uh
finding parallel illumination centering
the apertures
should you use an object aperture that
will be centered as well and all that
will be performed fully automatically
so there are two levels of screening
here the first one was Atlas acquisition
and it takes uh from first inserting the
grid to the microscope into the
microscope getting to the point that an
atlas is required it takes about uh
10 10 to 15 minutes
and uh
this already gives us insights about ice
quality and whether we want to Pro
proceed with the grid so here for
example at the level of Atlas uh the ice
thickness does look promising enough uh
for us
to proceed
to maybe either screen further or maybe
even acquire some data and
here when we
took an image at a higher magnification
so to speak we notice that the particles
are disintegrated somewhat uh the ice
quality is good so what that tells me
for example is that my vitrification
conditions are good but my biochemistry
is not so I need to revisit biochemistry
before I can get best possible
resolution from this data uh and
that's the information uh as an example
that I could get from this sample
so uh with that in mind I also want to
introduce another software that uh that
is available uh
to you for tundra
indeed uh
everything uh in the workflow as I just
showed was performed out of epu whether
it were the alignments or data
acquisition setup uh but there is
another software called microscope
companion or or micro per shot which is
uh available and it does house some uh
some uh Nifty little uh functions uh and
a couple of them are uh
import are important and fundamental to
your workflow uh so what is available
here is uh
for example your uh your column overview
vacuum status so you can of course close
your column valves from here you can
execute crash cycle from here uh status
of electron Source high tension status
of stage uh alignments this is something
that becomes quite interesting uh should
you want to live monitor uh what's
happening uh while if you is executing
alignments so there are two levels of
alignments as I said from epu when you
push the recover button in epu epu
performs and a set of alignments which
we call Daily alignments
should you want to acquire a full data
set uh if you perform a set of
alignments called optimize beam
alignments and they can all of these can
be live monitored
in micro
and this is where this is the only place
where micro becomes uh fundamental or
required to be to be used which is to
acquire reference images so here
it's again done with push of a button
and takes only a couple of minutes I
need to measure those and once I am in
the correct dose range I need to acquire
a full set of gain reference
and uh the last button is an Optics
button where you uh where you can
measure uh beam diameter
so uh to conclude uh in tundra we see
that uh
it's very easy to use uh even if you are
not an expert or if you're not familiar
with electron microscopy in in general
it's quite easy to transition uh into
electron microscopy and also uh
becomes quite easy to not not just
screen your grids
but also to collect uh
big uh single particle analysis driven
data sets should you want to do so
and with that we can conclude this
demonstration
thank you very much to the nanoport for
that fantastic demonstration
and here this will just be a summary
slide before we transition into some
question and answers but really what
what I'm trying to highlight with this
slide is just the broad range of
applications that
the tundra can assist with and
cryoelectron microscopy more generally
is able to
help with and so obviously you can do
you know so-called traditional
structural determination using Chrome
electron microscopy in the tundra
specifically and we have some examples
here that Natalia during her
introduction elaborated on in more
detail but there's one area that you
know we we didn't touch upon but Crow
electron microscopy can really help with
nanoparticle characterization and so we
have some examples here
of how that's able to to Aid research we
can answer some questions about that in
the Q a if there's any questions there
and
really the the key point that you would
have seen during the demo is just how
straightforward and accessible the the
tundra is and so we have a diagram here
in the sample optimization line where
you're using that structural information
that you're getting from the tundra to
help optimize your sample and as you saw
with the nice resolutions that you can
get on the tundra you can obviously be
satisfied in some cases with
that level of data but if you require to
move to a higher resolution well you
have already
optimize your sample so when you go to a
glacios or a query or some other
instrument you then have a lot more
confidence that your sample is going to
be able to achieve you know whatever
resolution you're you're looking for
and within all of this when you saw the
nanoport operating the tundra I think
probably the key takeaway was just how
you know straightforward and accessible
the microscope is so
um you know it's possible that some
people approach chromium with the idea
that it's going to be a little bit
difficult and maybe not so accessible to
you know a range of different
researchers and Labs but really you can
see just how straightforward and how
much effort has gone into really
optimizing and improving the process so
that you know anyone
more or less can access car electron
microscopy and operate these microscopes
and so I think with that
um just once again thank you to the
nanoport for the great demo and we'll
transition into into question and
answers thank you
yes I love seeing that time lapse video
of the installation of the instrument it
was so fun to see how uh quick and easy
it appears to be when you look at it in
that method also I love seeing the
nanopore demonstration thank you so much
Vera uh for that I've heard from new
users who are kind of intimidated in
getting started and really seeing a demo
from the nanoport in that format just
makes it much more accessible as you've
been said to a wider range of users so
really think this is going to be
groundbreaking and exposing more people
to cryoheum who might want to get
started
all right so thank you to our team who
is on for a q a session we do have just
a few minutes left for questions
um but I'm very happy to uh start us off
with um let's see the first question uh
looks like a pharmaceutical question so
Zubin uh could you please take this one
does the tundra have high enough
resolution to do single particle
analysis for a pharmaceutical
applications
thanks for the the question Tara and
absolutely the the examples that Natalia
shared during her talk I mean we have
resolutions from 2.6 to 4.2 angstrom
resolution and that is very very
sufficient to answer a lot of questions
that you know relevant to not only
academic research but also
pharmaceutical research
um and critically as I just mentioned in
the in the little talk five seconds ago
the tundra gives you this rapid feedback
on your sample so you can optimize
biochemistry so you can make really
quick decisions and that's one of the
critical factors in in Pharmaceuticals
is you need something that can give you
that quick structural information and
then obviously you can stay with the
tundra or you know that your sample is
going to be sufficient if you move to a
you know higher end collection
microscope so absolutely thank you for
the question
yeah great points thank you and uh yeah
I think already we're seeing some
widespread adoption uh from from Pharma
companies with uh with the tundra so
it's nice to see
um all right next question uh maybe
um beer or Cedric if you could briefly
answer uh how long does it actually take
to load a sample and start data
collection so what we saw was that in
lifetime
um what's the actual time
so it takes about 10 minutes to load the
sample to the microscope and it would
take another three minutes to five
minutes to collect a full Atlas which is
your low magnification map of nearly the
entire grid
so I would say a total of 15 minutes
approximately to get to your first
image of the grid
then if you like the screening part and
you want to collect a full data set it
would take about 10 more minutes to do
finer alignments
and let's say five minutes or so to
select a few good grid squares and so so
overall if you if you just want to
screen the Grid it's about 15 minutes of
time and if you want to get started with
the spa data collection
it would be let's say another 15 minutes
or so
perfect really amazing that uh that you
could go to uh loading to Imaging that
quickly it is a game changer I think in
a lot of ways
all right and uh maybe just one really
quick question for Natalia
um is the sample loading procedure
easier than using a side entry yeah
yes of course uh you know uh I have
plenty of experience with the site
healthy holder assistance and they are
much more complicated to use you need to
have service parties to be able to load
the samples especially under cardio
conditions without you know breaking the
vacuum in the microscope or you know
contaminating your your sample so with
the tundra as you can see it's very very
very easy of fuse I mean it's very cool
techniques and they are Auto grids so
you can totally recover those grids you
have a high connectivity with other
systems uh in our portfolio so very very
very it's like going from day to night
so it's a huge difference in Improvement
and ease of use
perfect thank you so much all right uh
so now we'll wrap up the session and I'd
really like to thank everybody who
joined in uh to uh with us today and who
asked these interesting questions we
will make this uh webcast available
along with all of our other uh recorded
webinars uh you can find them on our
website or please reach out to any of us
here our in-person events are continuing
around the U.S and expanding more around
the world in the coming months so if you
missed any of these events uh please
connect with your uh local contact to
schedule something at your own facility
thank you so much to our speakers and
for the nanoport demo team and
especially to everybody who joined us
today
until the next time goodbye
[Music]